i think that everybody has been asked at
least once to
share their data with a company under
the promise that the data
is anonymous so the problem is that
the data that is collected is
very rarely truly anonymous and this is
what i'm gonna
explain today
first of all the intuition of why this
is true is that
data that is supposedly anonymous can
often be re-identified
and a very good example of this was
given by an article of the new york
times
which was published i think about one
year ago
where the journalists could get their
hands on a big
data set a big location data set about
12 billion
and 12 million americans uh so
the way this uh data set looks like is
basically that
uh there are different users so like
let's say
bob alice carlos and
so on and for each of these users there
is a series
of location and data points so for
example for bob
we have t1 and l1 so time
one and location one and so on teach you
and so on and the same for alice and
carlos and all the users
and of course like we can represent this
on a map
as a trajectory so we have the first
point for bob which would be
t1 l1 and i don't i don't know like
maybe this could be that
you know bob was at madison square
garden like you know yesterday
at 8pm something like that then bob goes
to t2 l2 and we have a record for that
and so on and we have of course all of
this for all the users
in the data set now actually the data
set that the new york times
journalists could get access to did not
have
the names in it it was what we say is
pseudonymous
we can consider this like kind of
anonymous but however
uh the uh the journalists nevertheless
could reidentify
some people in this data set and follow
their movements
and actually some of the people who were
reidentified
were some collaborators of the u.s
president
so now the question is uh how did they
do it
how was it possible for them to identify
this data set even though
the names were not in it and the
intuition
of how you could do this is
to use some background information about
the person that you are trying to
identify and use it
to match it against the records and the
trajectories
in the data set so this is precisely the
idea
behind a study that was published in
2013 by some researchers
which studied this fact from a more
formal
point of view so what the researchers
did
was to define a metric unicity
which we call epsilon p which is defined
as the fraction of users in the data set
that are unique given p points
so at this point we're using this metric
they took a data set a location data set
very similar to the one of the
the new york times so a location data
set about uh one and a half
million people uh observed over a period
of i think 15 months or something like
that
and they computed the unicity values on
this data set
and what they found was that epsilon
4 was 95
this means that 95 of the times
only four points are necessary
to uniquely identify an individual in
the data set
so in other words if you know you know
like where i live
where i work uh where i had dinner
yesterday
and uh maybe where i go to train in the
in the weekend
then most of the times these are enough
to uniquely identify
my trajectory in the data set and once
you can find
my trajectory you can see all the other
places
that i've been visiting for the past 15
months
this study uses a pretty simple attack
setting right so basically the adversary
is assumed to have access to four points
about the the target the victim and uses
these four points directly to match
them against the data in the data set
so okay this is a this is a a potential
a potential setting
and but you could think of um
more complex attack settings for example
you could
you could assume that the the background
information that is available to the
adversary
uh is actually referred to a period
which is different
previous to the one of the data set that
you are trying to
reidentify we can suppose that we have
two data sets one from 2018
this data set also contains the names
so you know that this one is bob this
one is
alice the third one is carlos
and so on so you have the location
trajectories plus the names
then you have another data set from 2020
which has again you know all the uh
trajectories of all the users and so on
but in this case you do not have the
names
you just have some pseudonyms so for
example this is
user one user two user three
and so on now for simplicity we can also
assume that
the two data sets contain the same users
so
we can write this but we do not know
which users correspond to which ones
right
so it might be for example that bob is
u3
and alice is u1
and carlos is u2 so
the attacker doesn't know this but the
the aim
of the attacker is precisely to find out
the correct maxim between the users
in the 2018 data set and the users in
the 2020 data set
in this case we cannot uh use the the
method that we we
used before right because if we try to
match
the points in in the data set on the
left with the points in the data set of
the right
we find no matchings because the time
periods that
uh this refers to are exactly there is
no overlap
exactly so we need to find something
more more clever and one possible way to
approach
to approach this problem is to proceed
with two steps the first step is to
find a similarity score between
all the users and the second step
is to use all these this scores that we
have computed
in order to find a good global matching
between
all the users on the left and all the
users on the right
so we have here matching so i will go
now a little bit more in detail for
these two steps
i will assume for simplicity that there
are only three users
in each data set of course this is a an
oversimplified setting right but it's
just to to make things clearer
the first step is to find similarity
scores between users
what you do would be to take alice's
record
and you once record and you compute
the similarity score between these two
and you maybe you find you know like
that this is a
26 percent then you do the same between
alice and u2 and you find that this is
i don't know 35 then
ali send you three and you find
87 so you know like in this case
it looks quite likely that uh alice
and u3 actually are the same the same
person
but it's not always so easy you know
like because the problem is that now you
have to do
the same also for bob and u1
two and three and carlos and you want
u2 and your three and sometimes it's
quite clear
which one is the right match but
sometimes it's not that clear
so now the main question for this step
is
how do we compute the similarity
between two trajectories so there are a
lot of ways
to do this one simple one for example
here for
alice we compute the set of preferred
locations
so the locations that alice visits the
most often
and we do the same for u1 and then we
compare them
and the idea is that uh if the two sets
of preferred location
kind of overlap then probably this is a
good match and of course like this
might not always work right i mean maybe
alice changed the
workplace or maybe that italian
restaurant that she used to love
had to close down because of brexit
whatever but the idea is that on
average if the overlapping is good
enough then probably
the the matches is a correct okay
so and so this this is the first step
the second step is
the matching so now we have all the
scores between the users
but we need to find what is the correct
matching so here the idea is to
select the matching that maximizes
the overall similarity between users
what you can do
is to try all possible matchings and
compute the similarity scores for that
so for example we can start
from this very simple matching in the
same order
we compute the similarity score for this
one
and we proceed with the next matching so
maybe we can do this one we do this
this and this and we compute the
similarity matrix so this would be like
similarity one
similarity score two of course this is
the similarity again
for all the uh like the sum of all the
similarities
score for for all the the users and we
proceed like this for all the matchings
now the problem is that uh this strategy
works uh in theory but it doesn't work
in practice if the data set
is uh too big and actually it doesn't
have to be all that big because you know
for those of you who love combinatorics
you can see that the number of all
possible matchings that you have to try
is n factorial where
n is the number of users in the data set
if n
is just three users then three factorial
is just
six so this is totally doable but
if the number of users is one thousand
for example
then one thousand factorial is a huge
number
it takes i think 2 500 digits
just to be written down so basically you
know computing
the global similarity for 1000 users
in this way would be would take forever
it would take like you know millions and
millions of years
so we cannot do that um fortunately
at least for the attacker there is uh
there is a there are
well-known algorithms that do precisely
this so they compute
a maximum weight maximum matching
in in an efficient way so one such
algorithm
is the hungarian algorithm
i will not go into the details of this
algorithm because you know like it's
quite complex
uh but you can find some very good uh
videos online
if you're if you're interested so
basically once you
once you have this similarities course
you use the hungarian algorithm to find
the the
maximal matching the the most most
likely matching
and you use that matching as a guess for
uh the identification of the the users
in the
in the 2020 data set and
this attack uh works pretty pretty well
at least
when the data set is not too big so a
few thousand users
uh but there are you know like other
solutions that are more robust and like
you know work
also for for uh bigger data sets
so uh i hope i gave an idea of why
you know anonymous data can often be
re-identified so i talked about location
data but
actually these kind of attacks work for
most types of
um of a behavioral data so all social
networks and so on credit card data
so now one when you when you see this
these attacks you could think that it's
really impossible to
to share data to analyze data without
compromising uh
privacy and this is actually
a problem because you know sometimes you
do
want to uh give the possibility to
analyze data so for example you know
uh you might want to to be able to share
uh health data for medical research but
actually i mean there are there are a
lot of
examples of how to how one can use data
for
uh for good um so the good news
is that uh some i mean many
researchers and cryptographers
are you know developing technologies
that allow precisely to analyze data
without compromising the privacy of the
individuals who
who contribute with their data but this
is for another video
and then down here for each of the value
as i'm writing it out i go round in a
loop
around the amount of stretches i want
and i basically add in new data
so if i'm going from this point to this
point any device
which is keeping track of time in that
way we'll get
really confused and we basically get